When America voted in 2020,
there was one issue both Republicans
and Democrats could agree on:
"An overwhelming majority of voters said yes
to the legalization of marijuana."
"Montana voters gave their
clear backing to marijuana."
"Arizona, South Dakota..."
"You could say a lot of New Jersey voters
are high tonight."
New Jersey arrests around 30,000 people a
year for marijuana possession,
more than almost any other state.
But this year they voted to legalize marijuana.
Arizona voted to legalize it, too.
So did Montana.
So did South Dakota.
Medical marijuana was passed in Mississippi.
Now one in three Americans live in a state
where access to marijuana has been legalized.
Oregon took it even further and decriminalized
possession of all drugs on Election Day.
Over decades, America’s war on drugs has
put millions of people in prison.
And today it’s widely understood to have
disproportionately affected people of color.
For example, Black Americans use marijuana
at the same rates as White Americans,
but are arrested for it at a much higher rate.
This map shows that more
and more Americans are starting to turn
against the country’s harsh drug laws.
But ending them entirely
will be a lot more complicated.
Americans used to be almost unanimously
against legalizing marijuana.
Today, two out of
three Americans support it.
But politicians, not so much.
There's a lag, between public embrace of issues,
particularly cannabis policy,
and state legislators,
or even members of Congress.
John Hudak is a policy researcher who writes
about America’s marijuana policies.
And he says the gap between how politicians
and the public feel about marijuana,
has a lot to do with
what kind of political issue it is:
Most Americans don't use cannabis.
Most Americans have never been arrested for a
cannabis-related offense, etc.
So it ends up not being something
that they are going to hold
elected officials accountable for.
Americans usually choose who they vote for
because of issues like
the economy, or health care.
Issues like marijuana are pretty far down
the list of priorities.
But when you ask them directly, Hey,
do you want marijuana legalized? They'll say yes.
And that’s why almost all of these states
have legalized marijuana in a very similar way:
Instead of the state legislature passing a
comprehensive, detailed law,
it was put directly to the people on Election
Day, as a question on the ballot.
We have used ballot initiatives as a campaign
and advocacy tool for decades.
Lindsay LaSalle is a drug policy strategist,
and she’s worked on a lot of these
state ballot initiatives.
The legislature is often afraid to act.
But one problem with changing laws this way,
with a simple ballot initiative,
is that the state still has to figure out the details.
And that isn’t always easy.
For example, in New Jersey, no one really
knows what’s going to happen
to all the people who are incarcerated,
or have arrest records,
for something that's now legal.
The other challenge for these laws is that
they create a gap with the federal government.
Even though it’s legal in several states,
at the federal level marijuana is still classified
as one of the most serious drugs —
equal to heroin and LSD.
And that puts federal drug laws in direct
conflict with state laws in all sorts of ways.
Legal marijuana businesses have a really hard
time getting any federally-backed bank
to take their money.
And they can’t sell their product
across state lines.
So a farm in California
can’t sell to a store in Nevada,
even though it’s legal in both states.
And because the federal government considers
marijuana a controlled substance,
scientists researching the effects of it often
face problems with funding and testing.
But as more people in more states choose to
legalize marijuana,
this gap is going to become unsustainable.
Having the more conservative states, like South
Dakota and Montana and Arizona, passing it,
means that people have to consider it at the
federal level in a much more robust way.
We’ve seen something
similar happen before.
At first, same-sex marriage only became legal
in the US state by state.
But by 2015, 70% of Americans lived in states
that had legal same-sex marriage.
That same year, it became legal
throughout the country.
We've transformed, in this country,
in the course of about 25 to 30 years,
in terms of cannabis legalization being
an absolutely toxic and fringe issue,
which is what it was,
to one now where candidates
of both parties are embracing it.
Americans' attitudes on the war on drugs,
and the mass incarceration it led to, are changing.
And more and more of them
are ready for those laws to change.
But if politicians won’t do it,
they will.